A 2018 survey by Blind, an anonymous workplace chat app,...
...found that over 50% of the close to 11,500 tech workers surveyed answered 'yes'...
...when asked if they currently suffered from job burnout.
Compare that to a 2019 survey of 15,000 physicians,...
...only 42% of who said that they felt burnt out,...
...and the pandemic only seems to have made things worse.
A 2020 survey by Blind showed that 68% of tech workers felt more burnt out...
...while working from home than while working from the office.
The survey included over 3,000 employees working at companies...
...like Amazon, Microsoft, Facebook, Apple and Google.
Beyond the day-to-day pressure,...
...some said stagnation played a role in their decision to leave their tech jobs.
In fact, a 2020 survey of more than 4,000 tech workers found that following salary,...
...the opportunity to learn new skills was the second largest motivator...
...to accept a new job offer.
The same survey found that 58% of tech workers...
...would leave their current job for another one...
...if presented new challenges and problems to solve.